if you still have questions after
reaching the end of the netflix original
movie enola homes starring stranger
things phenom millie bobby brown we're
here to dive into the wise hows and
whodunits of the captivating caper
it's elementary dear viewer the central
mystery at the heart of anola homes is
kicked off by the disappearance of
anola's mother eudoria while anola's
older brother sherlock arrives to
investigate their mother's disappearance
zanola isn't satisfied to leave it to
him
she sets out on a quest to follow the
clues and solve the mystery of her
mother's disappearance all by herself
eventually enola's sleuthing leads her
to a warehouse marked by her mother's
distinctive purple ribbon
inside anola finds flyers for a meeting
of the national society of women's
suffrage
along with a pamphlet headed protest
unrest and civil disobedience and
containing instructions for constructing
an orsini bomb
moments later enola uncovers crates of
these bombs within the warehouse and
worries about what
exactly her mother has gotten herself
involved in we never actually learned
the specifics of what eudoria's group
was planning but it's safe to assume
that it was both dangerous and illegal
when eudoria visits anola at the end of
the movie she remains vague about the
specifics of her plans but does mention
that the reason she didn't tell anola
where she was going was because it
wasn't safe
adding that you have to make some noise
if you want to be heard since we never
hear of any sort of attack in enola
homes it seems probable that whatever
eudoria was planning
is still in the works an ola's quest to
find her mother kicks off when she
realizes that the little box of gifts
eudoria left her contains a cipher
its encoded message leads her to where
her mother is hidden a large stash of
money along with a cryptic note which
reads
our future is up to us enola interprets
this as an invitation to follow her
mother and immediately boards a train to
london hoping to find her
as she searches she leaves ciphers of
her own and a number of newspapers then
routinely scours the classified ads for
a response
enola is positive that her mother has
left her a puzzle that only she can
solve which will explain everything
but by the end of the film it becomes
clear that eudoria never intended for
anola to come after her and that anola's
actions have in fact taken her quite by
surprise
but if she didn't want her daughter to
follow her why did she leave a trail of
breadcrumbs for her to follow
well she probably didn't think that's
what she was doing more likely eudoria
was hoping to reassure anola that she
was alright and that no one needed to
come after her her short message was
probably the closest eudoria felt she
could come to giving anola an
explanation for why she'd left without
involving her in her dangerous plans
as for the money eudoria probably wanted
to make sure anola was well provided for
once she was gone and never dreamed
she'd use it to track her down
much is made in enola homes of eudorius
fondness for ciphers and anagrams and
she uses both to communicate with anola
at first when anola overhears her mother
talking about ellie houseman she assumes
that she must be a woman with some
connection to her mother
and resolves to find her however she
eventually realizes that her mother was
speaking in code
our choices bank men met
entangled her all early husband
all three of these names turn out to be
anagrams for london locations
the embankments bethnal green and
limehouse lane the women were discussing
possible locations for the next phase of
their plan
and ultimately decided on the warehouse
at limehouse lane when anola goes there
to investigate she finds activist flyers
sitting alongside crates full of
explosives indicating that whatever
eudoria and her allies are planning
isn't exactly going to be a peaceful
protest and ola never learns where the
demonstration itself was going to be
since limehouse lane is just the
location of their staging headquarters
whatever it is it's going to have to
wait since anola destroys all the
explosives in the warehouse while
escaping the sinister mr linthorn
when anola first meets by count tuksbari
the marquis of baselweather he appears
to simply be a sheltered young
aristocrat yearning for a bit of freedom
but they both quickly learn that someone
has actually hired a hitman to kill him
enola suggests that a member of his own
family may be behind the plots reasoning
that someone close to him has a lot to
gain by seizing two spirits votes in the
house of lords
enola's initial theory is that the
culprit must be tuksbury's uncle who
would inherit the estate in the event of
tookesbarry's death his uncle would also
have taken over tewksbury spots in the
lords giving him a pivotal vote on the
upcoming reform bill
however it turns out that anola was
wrong it was tewksbury's grandmother the
dowager who was plotting his demise not
his uncle
the dowager tips her hand when she talks
to a null after discovering her in
tookesbarry's treehouse
she tells anola that the role of an
ancestral landowner is to protect and
preserve old ideas in a rapidly changing
world
this extends in her mind to resisting
political change such as that contained
in the reform bill
although the dowager cares for her
grandson in her own way she thinks his
progressive ideas threaten her way of
life
and the only way to safeguard the future
of the country is to stop him before he
can begin pushing for change
after anola is attacked by mr linthorn
in his attempts to find and kill
tewksbari
she travels to bowser weather under the
guise of being sherlock holmes's
assistant
while roaming the grounds anola comes
across the tree branch tuxbury told her
about
the tree brunch broke above me as i was
collecting wild mushrooms
at the time tewksbari chalked up his
near-miss with death as a light bulb
moment prompting him to run away from
home and seek out the life he truly
desired but anola sees that the branch
has been cleanly sawed through
indicating that someone intentionally
dropped the branch on the boy
she then finds tewksbari's treehouse in
which he planted the clues that led
linthorn to limehouse lane enola quickly
realizes that the limehouse lane clues
were planted to misdirect anyone who
might pursue tukxbari she discovers his
real destination by looking at which
parts of his book seem the most well
visited with pressed flowers between the
pages indicating his intent to reinvent
himself
as a flower merchant it appears as
though tukesbari's number is up during
the climax of enola homes when his
grandmother finally reveals herself as
the mastermind behind the assassination
attempts and takes it upon herself to
shoot him in the chest
tukesbari is knocked flat on his back
and anola assumes he must be dead after
taking such a devastating shot to close
range
but moments later tewksbari sits up
revealing that the shotgun pellets were
stopped by a metal plate he was wearing
under his shirt
considering that tukxbari hadn't known
they were headed to basil weather until
lanola made a spur of the moment
decision
when did he have the opportunity to don
a makeshift bulletproof vest
the last we see of tukspari before he
attacks linthorn he watches a bullet
deflect off the metal chest plate right
beside his head
the plate came from a suit of armor that
linthorne had shot previously
causing the scattered pieces to fall
around tewksbury although we didn't see
it tooks barry must have quickly grabbed
the chest plate and tucked it underneath
his own shirt as protection before
jumping back into the fight
it didn't help when linthorne was trying
to strangle him but proved pivotal when
his grandmother shot him
the plot to assassinate tukesbari all
boils down to his vote on the reform
bill in the house of lords before
tookspari found himself in his
grandmother's crosshairs his father had
been in favor of the reform bill and it
passed his ideology along to his son
before his mother-in-law had him killed
the dowager is staunchly opposed to the
reform bill
furman her belief that the best thing
for the future of the country is to keep
things just the way they always have
been
and to actively resist significant
change but what exactly was the reform
bill anyway
although there are several noteworthy
reform bills in british history the one
at the center of enola homes is the
third reform act of 1884 a real piece of
legislation which extended the right to
vote to male tenants and landowners in
the countryside a right previously held
only by men
in the towns there's one thing this
country doesn't need
it's more uneducated voters the reform
bill significantly expanded the british
electorate making it an important step
on the road to universal suffrage
however despite its great strides
forward the reform bill was far from
perfect
it left 40 of men and all women without
a vote
and left anola and her mother with a lot
of work still to do
sherlock doesn't have many memories of
his sister anola as a child but one is
stuck with him
a bit of pine cone wrapped in wool
dragged it with wherever you went
calling it dash he later finds a wool
wrapped pine cone under eudora's pillow
and brings it to anola when he visits
her
boarding school when he gives it to her
he tells her that he finds her
extraordinary and gives her some
important brotherly advice
the choice is always yours whatever
society may claim
it can't control you at the end of the
film sherlock leaves anola a coded
message
posing as their mother in the hopes that
she'll come to meet him as he waits he
asks mycroft if he can be a nola's
guardian to which mycroft readily agrees
they both prepare to leave but then
sherlock notices that anola has left
dash on the statue at the center of the
courtyard
he looks around for a minute smiles then
replaces the pine cone and walks away
given their earlier conversation around
the pinecone this is likely anola's way
of letting sherlock know she's chosen to
make her own way in the world
and his way of giving her his blessing
when eudoria and anola finally reconnect
at the end of the film eudoria says
something that could seem rather odd if
you hadn't been paying close attention
thank you for your irises flowers play
an important role through ananola homes
beginning when eudoria leaves anola a
collection of hand-painted flower cards
each with its own associated meaning
when anola is placing encoded messages
in various newspapers earlier in the
film she refers back to these cards
thank you my chrysanthemum are you
blooming
send iris please iris means message
well there's no need for eudoria to
still be speaking in code when she sees
anola in person again
eudoria keeps using their secret shared
language to help show the close and
special bond between mother and daughter
although both of the cases anola takes
on have been solved by the end of enola
homes the film is still pretty
open-ended when it comes to anola
herself
her mother is still in hiding working
with her fellow suffragists to make a
better world through political activism
and not so civil
disobedience mycroft has gratefully
placed guardianship of anola to sherlock
and sherlock has in turn decided to let
anola forge her own path instead of
forcing her back under his roof so what
is that path
it's a little unclear although it
definitely seems like anola will be
carrying on her detective work she
closes out her story by declaring
i am a detective i am a decipherer
and i am a finder of lost souls
after telling us who she is she echoes
her brother and mother's earlier words
saying her life is her own and the
future is up to us it definitely leaves
the door open for future and nola holmes
films in which she could later team up
with sherlock or continue to establish a
name for herself independent to her
famous brother
whatever happens we can be sure that
anola will continue fighting for
equality and justice no matter where her
journey takes her
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one